foreign
hi there thanks so much for taking my
call you bet
I am on baby step one and I'm struggling
because I don't necessarily know how to
manage that feeling of insecurity I keep
getting of only putting a thousand
dollars in my emergency fund and then
moving on to baby step two oh this is a
really good question yeah so tell us
what you are specifically worried about
because I feel like I heard you say I'd
like to have more than a thousand saved
is that what this is really about is it
exactly how I'm feeling and like I'm
feeling like even when I do get a
thousand in it
um I'm not gonna have my budget where
it's cut out where I'm spending every
single dollar every month
um I just I'm scared something will come
up in a thousand dollars isn't enough to
cover okay so we'll be back in the spot
where I got to take out debt okay so do
you have margin feels like you've got
margin in your budget right now I do
what kind of margin do you have
uh it's going to be fluctuating
throughout the year
um but I'd say it's a good chunk once I
start getting rolling on my debt
snowball
what was that what is a good chunk when
you say that what does that mean is that
200 is that two thousand dollars so it's
going to fluctuate yeah some months it
will be like 300 some months it can be
up to five thousand okay perfect and how
much debt do you have
65 000. 65 000. what is that debt
uh 55 000 student loans 3 000 on
personal loans and then seven thousand
on a car loan okay and how much are you
making a year
uh 85 in between 85 and 105 000.
yeah good for you that's great
um so yeah I mean I think part of that
thousand dollar emergency funds
there there is going to be a level of
angst and urgency which makes people go
through the baby steps maybe step two
that much faster because they're like oh
my gosh I feel like if something were to
happen but the truth is Right majority
of emergencies that we see uh whether
it's new tires on a car you know
whatever it is most of it is under a
thousand dollars so majority of it is
and if not all you do is you pause the
debt snowball stay current on everything
pile up some cash with what you need
fixed and fix it and so just having the
idea that there's going to be no debt
the debt is not an option you find a way
to get through it all you find a way
like you really do so if it's the car
that's breaking down you go and get
three options and you fix the small part
that you can to get truck along to you
save up to fix the rest I mean you just
you figure you figure it out and so the
problem is that debt has just become
such a safety net for people that
mentally you can't even imagine you know
not having the credit card just in case
of an emergency and so that thousand
dollars will cover most of the stuff
that you need and if it doesn't you just
pause pile up some cash and go through
it and right here's the deal I love how
Rachel explained that because if you
think about that and she's right
factually most of those emergencies are
under a thousand dollars but I got to
the point when I first started this many
many years ago Rachel I didn't want to
touch the emergency fund and my first
step was not to touch the emergency fund
it was to rework the budget yeah totally
okay we paid our four walls but I mean I
would go can I cash flow this without
touching the emergency fund yep and Ray
with the margin you're talking about you
gave us a range of 300 on the low end to
maybe 5 000 because you've got you know
a little bit different income flow
you're gonna be able to be okay and I
remember one time I gave you one more
story here just to just to drive this
home psychologically I remember as early
on
and Stacy and I we had no kids and we
bought our first house here in Franklin
and we were on this journey we had
student loan debt there's only debt we
had and so we were working it and going
after all this stuff and our HVAC went
out and I mean I'm like you got to be
kidding me I'd never been through this
before didn't know what to expect it
freaked me out for a minute and I got
the guy out there and he was like all
right here's it we can do a small fix
and this will get you through
and then I started figuring out okay
what would if I have to buy a new one
you know what how much would that cost
and and by just not freaking out and
realizing I didn't have to pay anything
right now I didn't have to get out of
credit card and go buy a new unit there
was a way to work through it cash flow
it and let's not go backwards and we
never missed a debt payment that we were
paying extra on the loans here's my
point when something like that happens
you can always pause and figure it out
you can talk to the people that you get
the service from hey let me get on a you
know a plan here you know yeah
it's not the end of the world I think
everybody thinks I gotta have that
credit card I gotta have I mean we get
this call a lot when someone's got let's
say they've got forty thousand dollars
rate in their savings account and they
call us up and they got 38 000 in debt
and we go
empty it pay it now Ray you just felt it
right there didn't you
yeah and so this is a specifics we give
all the time because most of those
emergencies the point we're making is
you can manage your way through it you
can and Ray I mean a big part of this
too is feeling this intensity of getting
out of debt I mean like that's a huge
point we talk about the behavior change
aspect of all of this and you have to do
something different to get a different
result and you obviously are at a point
that you're not happy with where you are
financially so you want to change your
habits you want to change the way you're
looking at it and the more the faster
you attack this debt and it is gone and
it's out of here which you know you're
gonna you know if you guys buckle down
and you work extra you make some more I
mean you know to be able to get this
paid off in what probably three years uh
it there's something powerful about
having this intensity towards that baby
step two which is really key and so we
want that thousand dollars fast when we
tell people 30 days or less get that
sell stuff do whatever you can get a
thousand dollars and move on because you
want this momentum to start and the more
you kind of like play K okay well we
need like five thousand it's gonna take
us six months to save it up and you know
it just it just drags drags the process
on as your income continues to go to
payments so getting to that baby step
two quickly and going through it as
quickly as possible is really the is
your best bet to Building Wealth from
getting to point A to point B getting
your income back where it's yours is one
of the biggest things you can do so it's
the fastest way and again Ray you're
you're grown you're a grown-up you can
decide you can get off the call and
decide to do what you want but this has
just been proven over and over and over
and over and over and over and over yep
you know what you need Ray I think
Rachel's right you know what you need
you need a big win in the next week
so what's this lowest what's the
smallest debt was it the three thousand
dollar personal loan
uh yeah well one one is one thousand
left on it and one is two thousand okay
so the debt snowball you're familiar
with this yes yes all right how quickly
could you pay off that one thousand
dollar
chunk
I've budgeted in for September nah
that's that's I appreciate that I said
let's just have some fun here see we can
get you some momentum what could you do
ray
side something here there sell some
stuff
what could you do to get a thousand
dollars outside of your current income
before end of September what could you
do
uh yeah I mean I I need to sell my
vehicle and I could easily have that
done
well that's selling the vehicle I'm not
saying we got to jump to that because
that's one of your what's that vehicle
worth
uh I think it'd be I think it's worth it
on like 8 000 right now and I've got 7
000 left on it yeah but then you got
then you don't have a car I have another
vehicle that I get it's a work vehicle
that I can use
it
the Ray of Hope we needed oh I see what
she did there folks so we're doing do it
right do something crazy like sell the
car you'll get a thousand bucks you'll
yeah oh my gosh you'll have to knock out
two debts with that one per with that
one sale what's your car payment right
now on that uh 235 and I'm paying 150 in
Insurance boom you just you gave
yourself a raise yeah the car's gone
the personal is gone you're taking a
little bit out of that student loan and
you're on I mean you're getting there
Ray
you with us
yeah it's the heart I haven't even got
through baby step one though that's the
hard part I just need to do it sell the
car and get to baby step one done
yeah dude rip the Band-Aid off just do
it you gotta just decide it's one of
these things it's gonna feel so good she
was I watching on Instagram it was some
some health guy he's like you oh no no
you know who it was it was Tony Robbins
talking about some health guy talking
about his workout or something oh yeah
and he's like
there's no there's no negotiate you just
do it you just can't do it oh you're
negotiating yeah just just jumping just
do it just do it so Ray
well Tony Robbins cold plunge just do it
jump in the cold water just do it it's
gonna be right